How Do We Represent a Set of the First
Three Natural Numbers When we come to write a
set of elements on a piece of paper we ca
n't just write it in a happy manner there are a few
defined ways in which we can
represent sets let's  C One of the wedges in
that we can write it Open the brackets
one to three and close the brackets We use
the curly brackets to mark the start
and the end of the set The set starts here and
ends here Inside the brackets we have
elements  So each of these three numbers is an
element some times we may also refer to them as members
and the last thing we need to
observe is that we use causes to separate
the elements. This is a very clear and concise way
to represent sets and is
called  The Listing and the Raster
Method It's a Very Simple Way to Represent Sets
All We Have to Do Is List the Elements
Down We'll Look at More Ways of
Representing This Set in the Next
[Music]
Video